what if the state covered your cost of
living would you still go to work go
back to school not work at all what
would you do this concept is called a
universal basic income or ubi and it's
nothing less than the most ambitious
social policy of our times in 2017 basic
income is gaining momentum around the
world first trials are ongoing or on
their way and the growing number of
countries are considering ubi
as an alternative to welfare how would
it work and what are the key arguments
for and against right now people can't
really agree what universal basic income
is or should be some want to use it to
eliminate welfare and Cupp bureaucracy
others want it as a free extra for
existing programs or even want it to be
so high that work itself becomes
optional for this video we'll talk
mostly about the minimum basic income
enough money to be above the poverty
line in the US this means about $1,000 a
month or $12,000 a year
the money would not be taxed and you
could do whatever you wanted with it in
this scenario ubi is a way of
transferring the wealth of a society
while still keeping the free market in
tax but if we hand out free money will
people just spend it on booze and stop
working a 2013 study by the World Bank
specifically examined if poor people
waste their handouts on tobacco and
alcohol if they receive it in the form
of cash
the clear answer no they don't the
opposite is true other studies have
shown that the richer you are the more
drugs and alcohol you consume the lazy
and drunk poor person is a stereotype
rather than reality
what about laziness universal basic
income test runs done in Canada in the
1970s showed that around 1% of the
recipients stopped working mostly to
take care of their kids on average
people reduce their working hours by
less than 10% the extra time was used to
achieve goals like going back to school
or looking for better jobs but if
laziness and drugs are not a huge deal
why doesn't our current welfare state
solve poverty welfare or unemployment
programs are often come with a lot of
strings attached like taking part in
courses applying to a certain number of
jobs a month or accepting any kind of
job offer no matter if is a good fit or
what it pays besides the loss of
personal freedom these conditions are
often a huge waste of time and only
served to make the unemployment
statistics seem less backed often your
time would be much better spent looking
for the right job continuing education
or starting a business
another unwanted side effect of many
welfare programs is that they trap
people in poverty and promote passive
behavior imagine a benefit of $1,000
each month in a lot of programs if you
earn a single dollar extra the whole
thing is taken away if you take a job
that's paying $1200 you might not only
lose your benefits but because of your
taxes and another costs like
transportation you might end up having
less money than before so if you
actively try to better your situation
and your total income is not improving
or even a shrinking welfare can create a
ceiling that traps people in poverty and
rewards passive behavior a basic income
can
because and therefore getting a job and
additional income would always make your
financial situation better work is
always rewarded instead of a ceiling it
creates a floor from which people can
lift themselves up but even if you bi is
the better model is it economically
feasible
what about inflation well prices just
rise making everything just like it was
before since the money is not being
created by magic or printers it needs to
be transferred from somewhere it's more
of a shift of funds than the creation of
new ones
hence no inflation ok but how do we pay
for it there's no right answer here
because the world is too diverse how
well-off the country is what the local
values are are things like high taxes or
cutting the defense budget politically
acceptable or not how much welfare state
is already in place and is it effective
each country has its own individual path
to a ubi the easiest way to pay for a
ubi is to end all welfare and use the
free funds to finance it not only would
this make a number of government
agencies disappear which in itself saves
money it would also eliminate a lot of
bureaucracy on the other hand cutting
them could leave many people worse off
than before if the goal is to have a
foundation for everybody there still
need to be programs of some sort because
just like countries people are not the
same the second way higher taxes
especially for the very wealthy in the
US for example there's been a lot of
economic growth but most of the benefits
from it have gone to the richest few
percent
the wealth gap is rapidly widening and
many argue that it might be time to
distribute the spoilers more evenly to
preserve the social piece there could be
taxes on financial transactions capital
land value carbon or even robots but UPI
is not necessarily expensive according
to a recent study a UPI of $1,000 per
month in the US could actually grow the
GDP by 12% over eight years because it
would enable poor people to spend more
and increase overall demand what about
the people who do the dirty work who
will work in the fields crawl through
sewers all if pianos if you don't need
to for survival will people still do
hard boring and unfulfilling labor you
bi might give them enough leverage to
demand better pay and working conditions
a study calculated that every extra
dollar going to wage earners would add
about $1 21 to the national economy
while every extra dollar going to
high-income Americans would add only 39
cents there would still be very rich and
poor people but we could eliminate fear
suffering and existential panic for a
significant part of the population
making poor citizens better off could be
a smart economic tactic for some this
isn't enough they want a ubi large
enough to live a middle-class existence
if we set the financial obstacle aside
this idea fundamentally challenges how
our society is constructed by earning
money you earn the possibility to take
part in society this determines your
status and options but it also forces
many people into spending huge chunks of
their time on things they don't care
about
in 2016 only 33% of US employees were
engaged at work 16% were actively
miserable and the remaining 51% were
only physically present would 67% of
people stop working if they could it
would be unfair to portray work as just
a chore work gives us something to do it
challenges us it motivates us to improve
it forces us to engage many find friends
or partners at work we work for social
status wealth and our place in the world
we're looking for something to do with
our lives and for many people work gives
them meaning there are other concerns
with ubi if all welfare programs were
exchanged for one single payment this
gives the government a lot of leverage
individual programs are easier to attack
or cut than a multitude or populist
smite promise drastic changes to the ubi
to get into power and a universal basic
income doesn't tackle all problems when
it comes to equality rents for example
while $1,000 might be great in the
countryside it's not a lot for expensive
metropolitan areas which could lead to
poor people moving outwards and the
difference between rich and poor
becoming even more extreme and of course
for some people the concept of work
itself not being essential for survival
is appalling so is the universal basic
income a good idea the honest answer is
that we don't know yet there needs to be
a lot more research more and bigger test
runs we need to think about what kind of
ubi we want and what we're prepared to
give up to pay for it the potential is
huge it might be the most promising
model to sustainably eliminate poverty
it might seriously reduce the amount of
desperation in the world and make us all
much less stressed out this video was
made possible by a universal basic
income provided by you our viewers ten
thousand people around the world gift us
a monthly income on patreon.com slash
course cos art you enable us to pay
salaries and buy new hardware you enable
us to make more videos and you enable us
to spend more time on them courtesans
would truly not be what it is today
without your help you help us stay
independent and you give us the freedom
to go quality before quantity thank you
so much
[Music]